my fellow leaders
in the last year our world has
experienced great upheaval
a growing crisis in food insecurity
record heat floods and droughts
cover 19.
inflation
and a brutal needless War
a war chosen by one man to be very blunt
let us speak plainly
permanent member of the United Nations
security Council invaded its neighbor
tempted to erase a sovereign state from
the map
Russia has shamelessly violated the core
tenants of the United Nations Charter
no more important
than the clear prohibition
against countries taking the territory
of their neighbor by force
again just today
President Putin has made over nuclear
threats against Europe
a reckless disregard
for the responsibilities of the
non-proliferation regime
now
Russia's calling calling up more
soldiers to join the fight
and the Kremlin is organizing a sham
referendum to try to Annex parts of
Ukraine
and extremely significant violation of
the U.N Charter
this world should see these Outrageous
Acts for what they are
Putin claims he had to act
because Russia was threatened
but no one threatened Russia
and no one other than Russia
sought conflict
in fact
we warned it was coming
and with many of you we worked to try to
avert it
Putin's own words
make his true purpose unmistakable
just before he invaded Putin asserted
and I quote
Ukraine was created by Russia and never
had quote real statehood
and now we see
tax on schools
Railway stations hospitals
one on centers of Ukrainian history and
culture
the past
even more horrifying evidence of
Russia's atrocity and war crimes
Mass Graves uncovered in ism
bodies
according to those who escalated those
bodies showing signs of torture
this war
is about extinguishing Ukraine's right
to exist as a state
plain and simple
and Ukraine's right to exist as a people
whoever you are
wherever you live
whatever you believe
that should not that should make your
blood run cold
that's why 141 nations in the general
assembly
came together
and not to unequivocally condemn
Russia's war against Ukraine
the United States has marshaled massive
levels of security assistance and
humanitarian Aid and direct economic
support for Ukraine
more than 25 billion dollars to date
our allies and partners around the world
have stepped up as well
and today
more than 40 countries represented in
here have contributed billions
of their own money and equipment to help
Ukraine defend itself
the United States is also working
closely with our allies and partners to
impose costs on Russia
to deter tax against NATO territory the
whole Russia accountable for the
atrocities and war crimes
because if Nations can pursue their
Imperial Ambitions without consequences
then we put at risk everything is very
institution stands for everything
every Victory one in the battlefield
belongs in the craziest Ukrainian
soldiers but this past year
world was tested as well
and we did not hesitate
we chose Liberty we chose sovereignty
we told we chose principles to which
every party
to the United Nations Charter is
beholding
we stood with Ukraine
like you
the United States wants this war to end
on just terms
on terms we all signed up for
that you cannot seize a nation's
territory by force
that the only country
standing in the way of that is Russia
so we each of us in his body who
determined to uphold the principles and
beliefs we pledge to defend as members
of the United Nations must be clear
firm
and unwavering in our resolved
Ukraine has the same rights that belong
to every Sovereign Nation
we will stand in solidarity with Ukraine
we will stand the solidarity against
Russia's aggression period
now it's no secret
than the contest between democracy and
autocracy
the United States and I as president
Champion a vision for our world as
grounded in The Valleys of democracy
the United States is determined to
defend and strengthen democracy at home
and around the world because I believe
democracy remains Humanity's greatest
instrument
to address the challenges of our time
we're working with the G7 unlike-minded
countries to prove democracies can
deliver for their citizens but also
deliver for the rest of the world as
well
but as we meet
today the UN Char the U.N Charter is
very basis of a stable and just
rule-based order is under attack
by those who wish to tear it down were
distorted for their own political
advantage
and the United Nations Charter
was not only signed by democracies of
the world
it was negotiated
among citizens dozens of Nations
with vastly different histories and
ideologies unite it and their commitment
to work for peace
as President Truman said in 1945 the U.N
Charter and I quote is proof that
Nations like men
can State their differences can face
them
and then can find common ground on which
to stand end of quote
that Common Ground was so
straightforward so basic
today 193 of you 193 member states have
willingly embraced his principles
and standing up for those principles
for the U.N Charter is the job of every
responsible member state
I reject
the use of violence and War to conquer
Nations or expand borders through
bloodshed
to stand against global politics of fear
and coercion
to defend the Sovereign rights of
smaller Nations as equal to those of
larger ones to embrace basic principles
like freedom of navigation
respect for international law and arms
control
no matter what else we may disagree on
that is the common ground upon which we
must stand
if you're still committed to a strong
foundation for the good of every nation
around the world
then the United States wants to work
with you
I also believe the time has come for
this institution to become more
inclusive so they can better respond to
the needs of today's world
members of the U.N security Council
including the United States should
consistently uphold and defend the U.N
Charter and refrain refrain from the use
of the veto except in rare extraordinary
situations
to ensure the council remains credible
and effective
that is also why
the United States supports increasing
the number of both permanent and
non-permanent representatives of the
council
this includes permanent seats for those
Nations we have long supported
impermanent seats for countries in
Africa Latin America and the Caribbean
the United States is committed to this
vital work
in every region we pursued new
constructive ways to work with Partners
to advance shared interests from
elevating the quad and indo-pacific to
signing the Los Angeles Declaration of
migration and protection at the summit
of the Americas
to joining a historic meeting of nine
Arab leaders to work toward a more
peaceful integrated Middle East
to hosting the U.S Africa leader Summit
in this December
as I said last year
the United States is opening an era of
Relentless diplomacy
to address the challenges that matter
most to people's lives all people's
lives
tackling climate crisis as a previous
spoker speaker spoke to
strengthening Global Health security
feeding the world feeding the world
we made that priority and one year
leader we're keeping that promise
from the day I came to office we've LED
with bold climate agenda we rejoined the
Paris agreement convened the major
climate summits help deliver critical
agreements on the cop 26.
we helped get two-thirds of the world
GDP on track
to limit warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius
and now
I've signed a historic piece of
legislation here in the United States
that includes the biggest most important
climate commitment we have ever made in
the history of our country
369 billion dollars
toward climate change
that includes tens of billions in new
Investments and offshore wind and solar
doubling down on zero emission vehicles
increasing Energy Efficiency
supporting clean Manufacturing
our department of energy estimates that
this new law will reduce U.S emissions
by one gigaton a year by 2030.
while unleashing a new era of clean
energy-powered economic growth
our investments will also help reduce
the cost of developing Clean Energy
Technologies worldwide not just in the
United States
this is a global game changer
and none too soon we don't have much
time
we all know we're already living in a
climate crisis
no one seems to doubt it after this past
year
we meet
we meet much of past we meet much of
Pakistan is still underwater
needs help
meanwhile the Horn of Africa faces
unprecedented drought
families are facing impossible choices
choosing which child to feed
and wondering whether they'll survive
this is the human cost of climate change
and it's growing not lessening
so as I announced last year
to meet our Global responsibility
my Administration is working with our
Congress to deliver more than 11 billion
dollars a year
to International climate Finance
to help lower income countries Implement
their climate goals and ensure adjust
energy transition
the key part of that will be our pepfar
plan
which will help half a billion people
especially vulnerable countries
adopt
to the impacts of climate change and
build resilience
this need is enormous
so let this be the moment
refined within ourselves
the will to turn back the tide of
climate Devastation the devastation
and unlock a resilient sustainable clean
energy economy to preserve our planet
on global health
we've delivered more than 620 million
doses of covid-19 vaccine 216 countries
around the world
with more available to help meet
country's needs
all free of charge no strings attached
and we're working closely with the G20
in other countries in the United States
help lead the change to establish a
groundbreaking new fund for pandemic
prevention preparedness and response at
the World Bank
at the same time
we've continued to advance the ball
on enduring Global health challenges
later today
I'll host the seventh replenishment
conference for the global fund to fight
AIDS tuberculosis and malaria
with bipartisan support in our Congress
I have pledged to contribute up to six
billion dollars to that effort
so I look forward to welcoming a
historic round of pledges at the
conference resulting one of the largest
global Health fundraisers ever held in
all history
we're also taking down the food crisis
head on
with as many as 193 million people
around the world experience acute acute
food insecurity
a jump of 40 million in a year
today I'm announcing another 2.9 billion
dollars
and U.S support
for life-saving humanitarian and food
security assistance for this year alone
Russia in the meantime is pumping out
lies
trying to pin the blame for the crisis
the food crisis on the sanctions imposed
by many in the world for the aggression
against Ukraine
so let me be perfectly clear about
something
our sanctions
explicitly allow
explicitly allowed Russia the ability to
export food and fertilize it no
limitation
it's Russia's war that is worsening food
insecurity and only Russia can end it
I'm grateful for the work here at the
U.N including your leadership Mr
Secretary General establishing a
mechanism to export grain from Black Sea
ports in Ukraine that Russia had blocked
for months
and we need to make sure it's extended
we believe strongly
and the need to feed the world
that's why the United States is the
world's largest supporter of the world
food program with more than 40 percent
of its budget
we're leading support the leading
support of the UNICEF efforts to feed
children around the world
and take on a larger challenge of food
insecurity in the United States
introduced a call to action a road map
eliminating Global Food insecurity to
eliminating Global Food insecurity
that more than 100 Nation member states
have already supported
in June the G7 announced more than 4.5
billion dollars to strengthen food
security around the world
through usaids feed the future
initiative
the United States is scaling up
innovative ways to get drought and heat
resistant seeds into the hands of
farmers who need them
while Distributing fertilizer and
improving fertilizer efficiency that
farmers can grow more while using less
and we're calling on all countries to
refrain from Banning food exports or
hoarding grain while so many people are
suffering
because in every country in the world
no matter what else divides us
if parents cannot feed their children
nothing nothing else matters if parents
cannot feed their children
as we look to the Future
we're working with our partners to
update and create rules of the road for
new challenges we face in the 21st
century
we launched the trade and Technology
Council with the European Union to
ensure that key Technologies
key Technologies are developed and
governed in the way that benefits
everyone
with our partner countries and through
the U.N we're supporting and
strengthening the Norms of
responsibility responsible State
behavior in cyberspace and working to
hold accountable those who use cyber
attacks to threaten International Peace
and security
with partners and the Americas Africa
Europe and the Middle East and
indo-pacific we're working to build a
new economic ecosystem
well where every nation Every Nation
gets a fair shot and economic growth is
resilient sustainable and shared
that's why the United States is
championed a global minimum tax
and we will work to see it implemented
so major corporations pay their fair
share everywhere everywhere
it's also been the idea behind the
indo-pacific economic framework
which the United States launched this
year with 13 other indo-pacific
economies
we're working with our partners in asean
and the Pacific Islands to support a
vision
for a critical indo-pacific region that
is free and open Connected and
prosperous secure and resilient
together with Partners around the world
we're working this secure resilient
Supply chains to protect everyone from
coercion or domination
and ensure that no country can use
energy as a weapon
and as Russia's War roles Riles the
global economy
we're also calling on major Global
creditors including the non-paris club
countries
to transparently negotiate debt
forgiveness for lower income countries
to forestall
broader economic and political crisis
around the world
instead of infrastructure project that
generated huge and large debt without
delivering on the promised advantages
let's meet the enormous infrastructure
needs around the world with transparent
Investments high standard projects that
protect the rights of workers in the
environment key to the needs of the
communities they serve not to the
contributor
that's why the United States together
with fellow G7 Partners launched a
partnership for Global infrastructure
and investment
we intend to collectively mobilize
600 billion dollars
an investment through this partnership
by 2027
dozens of projects are already underway
industrial scale vaccine Manufacturing
in Senegal
transformative solar projects in Angola
first of its kind small modular nuclear
power plant Romania
these are investments that are going to
deliver returns not just for those
countries but for everyone
the United States will work with every
nation including our competitors
to solve Global problems like climate
change
climate diplomacy is not a favor
to the United States or any other Nation
and walking away
hurts the entire world
let me be direct about the competition
between the United States and China
as we manage shifting geopolitical
Trends the United States will conduct
itself as a reasonable leader
we do not seek conflict
we do not seek a cold war
we do not ask any Nation to choose
between the United States or any other
partner
but the United States will be unabashed
in promoting our vision of a free open
secure and prosperous world
and what we have to offer communities of
Nations
Investments that are designed not to
Foster dependency but to alleviate
burdens and help Nations become
self-sufficient
Partnerships not to create political
obligation but because we know our own
success
each of our successes increased when
other nations succeed as well
when individuals have the chance to live
in dignity
and develop their talents everyone
benefits
critical of that is living up to the
highest goals of this institution
increasing peace and security for
everyone everywhere
the United States will not waver in our
unrelenting determination to counter and
thwart the continuing terrorist threats
to our world
and we will lead with our diplomacy to
strive for peaceful resolution of
conflict
we seek to uphold peace and stability
across the Taiwan Straits we rang
committed to our One China policy which
has helped prevent Conflict for four
decades
and we continue to oppose unilateral
changes in the status quo by either side
we support an African union-led peace
process to end the fighting in Ethiopia
restore security for all its people in
Venezuela where years of political
oppression have driven more than six
million people from that country we urge
the venezuelan-led dialogue and return
to free and fair elections we continue
to stand with our neighbor in Haiti as
it faces political fuel gang violence an
enormous human crisis
and we call on the World to do the same
we have more to do
we'll continue to back the U.N mediated
truce in Yemen
which has delivered precious months of
peace
the people that have suffered years of
war
and we will continue to advocate for
lasting negotiating peace between the
Jewish and Democratic state of Israel
and the Palestinian people
the United States is committed to
Israel's security full stop
and a negotiated two-state solution
remains in our view the best way to
ensure Israel's security and prosperity
for the future and give the Palestinians
the state which to which they are
entitled
both sides
fully respect or equal rights of their
citizens both people enjoy an equal
measure of freedom and dignity
let me also urge Every Nation to
recommit to strengthening the nuclear
non-proliferation regime
through diplomacy
no matter what else is happening in the
world
the United States is ready to pursue
critical armed control measures
a nuclear war
cannot be won
and must never be fought
the five permanent members of the
security Council just reaffirmed that
commitment in January
but today
we're seeing disturbing trends
rosh hashan
the non-proliferation of proliferation
proliferation ideals embraced by Every
Other Nation at the 10th npt review
conference and again today as I said
they're making irresponsible nuclear
threats to use nuclear weapons
China is conducting an unprecedented
concerning nuclear buildup without any
transparency
despite our efforts to begin serious and
sustained diplomacy
the Democratic People's Republic of
Korea continues to blatantly violate U.N
sanctions
and while the United States is prepared
for
a mutual return to the Joint
comprehensive plan of action if Iran
steps up to its obligations
the United States is clear
we will not allow Iran to acquire a
nuclear weapon
I continue to believe that diplomacy is
the best way to achieve this outcome
the non-proliferation regime is one of
the greatest successes of this
institution
we cannot let the world now slide
backwards
nor can we turn the Blind Eye to the
erosion of Human Rights
perhaps singular among this body's
achievements stands the universal
Declaration of Human Rights
which is the standard by which our
forebears challenge us to measure
ourselves
they made clear in 1948
human rights are the basis for all that
we seek to achieve
and yet today in 2022
fundamental freedoms are at risk in
every part of our world
from the violations of in xinjiang
detailed recent reports by the office of
un U.S reports detailing by the U.S High
Commissioner
to the horrible abuses against
pro-democracy actress and ethnic
minorities
by the military regime in Burma to the
increased repression of women and girls
by the Taliban in Afghanistan and today
we stand with the brave citizens and the
brave women of Iran
who right now are demonstrating to
secure their basic rights
but here's what I know
the future will be won
by those countries that unleash the full
potential of their populations
where women and girls
can exercise equal rights
including basic Reproductive Rights and
contribute fully to building a stronger
economies
and more resilient societies
religious and ethnic minorities can live
their lives without harassment and
contribute to the fabric of their
communities where the lgbtq plus
Community individuals
live and love freely without being
targeted with violence where citizens
can question and criticize their leaders
without fear of reprisal
the United States will always promote
human rights
and the values enshrined in the U.N
Charter
in our own country and around the world
let me end with this
this institution
Guided by the U.N Charter
and the universal Declaration of Human
Rights is at its core
an act of dauntless hope let me say that
again
it's an act of dauntless hope
think about the vision
of those first delegates Wonder took a
seemingly impossible task
while the world was still smoldering
think about how divided
the people of the world must have felt
with the fresh grief of millions dead
the genocidal horrors of the Holocaust
exposed
that every right to believe only the
worst of humanity
instead they reach for what was best in
all of us
and they strove to build something
better
enduring peace
committee among nations
equal rights for every member of the
Human family
cooperation for the advancement of all
humankind
my fellow leaders
the challenge we face today are great
indeed
but our capacity is greater
our commitment must be greater still
so let's Stand Together
to again declare the unmistakable
resolve
that nations of the world are united
still
and we stand for the values of the U.N
Charter
that we still believe by working
together we can bend the Ark of History
toward a fear a more just world for all
our children although none of us have
fully achieved it
we're not passive witnesses to history
we are the authors of History
we can do this we have to do it
for ourselves
and for our future
for humankind
thank you for tolerance for listening to
me I appreciate very much God bless you
all